est ce que monsieur trudeau juste un
être doux vous fait perdre patience à
l'avant où on sait qu'on ne sera pas de
retour en europe est un patient doit on
trouve que vous précise beaucoup ils
auront terre lorsque moi ce serait quand
je comprends pas pour l'essai de
multiplier les façons de faire et on a
une collaboration extrêmement positif ça
veut pas dire pourquoi toujours
s'entendre surtout ils savent toujours
là juste d'être dos vous en avez pensé
quoi comme premier ministre à l'égard du
québec
je vais vous parler de justin trudeau
par des potes du bureau fédéral c'est
juste un petit doute mais j'évite de
d'entrer dans une dynamique de
personnalisation comme si le canada
c'était justin trudeau
tout le monde sait que le québec n'est
pas simple mais uniquement celui d'une
âme ses ministres c'est lui qui prend
les décisions utiles il décide avec le
conseil des ministres nous semble qu'il
serait normal et attendu qu'ils
participent à ce projet d'un compte tenu
de son importance
jeudi la population soulevez-vous la
revit à l'historique fédéralisme
prédateur
ouais les jabots de sédhiou gouvernement
que je fais là toujours ça ne
parviendrez dans ma vie prenez par
exemple un aérodrome ou encore une
antenne de télécommunication ville et le
gouvernement provincial peuvent
souhaiter que ce soit ménagé d'une
certaine façon si non pas du tout mais
puisque c'est de compétence fédérale
ottawa peut agir comme bon lui semble et
s'assurer que le citoyen qui paye ses
taxes ou municipal au provincial qu'au
fédéral et ceux du jeu possible que vous
parliez comme faut pour qu'on tienne
compte de mes intérêts à moi plutôt que
de décider sur bing
c'est quoi la stratégie qui était en
place pour la suite des choses pour
faire avancer vos dossiers
dans le contexte actuel oui depuis une
année la proche que nous avions
évidemment était de maximiser les
rapports auprès du cabinet du premier
ministre lui même s'il n'ya pas un
lieutenant peut-être qu'ils parlent
avoir plusieurs
l'ancien premier ministre conservateur
stephen harper avait un lieutenant
politique pour représenter les intérêts
du québec à ottawa
justin trudeau quoi qu'il n'en a pas de
besoin peut-être que c'est à nous de
décider de ses lieutenants de tenter
autant que faire se peut de parler à
différents ministres
[Musique]